we're here at our little yellow table in
honor of our red table talk family the
estefans gloria emily and lily
okay let's get into some subjects that
you're gonna tackle in season two
um let's start with plastic surgery i'm
interested to hear what you have to say
on that subject because i haven't messed
with this yet but i mean there might be
a point where i'm like just pulling a
ponytail
i don't know what are your thoughts on
this subject we talk about a ponytail
lived on the show and it's really
interesting because the people that are
on the show are in their 20s
and they've had
massive plastic surgery and one of them
regrets it greatly and the other one
embraces it and we've got we've checked
it all out i go i have a ponytail lift i
put a ponytail on and squeeze that hair
back as tight as possible no my mom
works with her face on ice like this no
no honestly i mean people think i've had
it i haven't done my back i've never had
it yet we don't say
we were interrogating
the plastic surgeon that came on the
show to talk about a lot of different
you and i need to go but i i also she
freaks out if i ever tell her hey i
don't know maybe like it and she goes
mom
i'm freaked out by it however i'll tell
you this we explore the duality of
unrealistic
beauty standards like what are you
seeing on instagram the fact that
kim kardashian we don't judge but the
way that her body is actually in real
life it's not in a you can't work out
and look like that right so
there are people who yeah you want to
alter your body you want to alter your
face i have tattoos you know what is it
for
have a 19 year old and she's the whole
day on filters and
you know you start worrying about you
know this generation because
you know this is instagram versus
reality right i know it's like when we
talked about plastic surgery in like the
70s and 80s and 90s it was because
people who are older wanted to look
younger now exactly younger people
who want to look like the
different
unrealistic alien yes you know it's not
in a harmful word but it's okay to use
that word because it's to describe just
that the features are not uh normal
human features that we're biologically
used to seeing right like those fillers
that are you know like so bigger like
the you know the brazilian but the bbl's
like jada just spoke about it as well
you know these are things that are
dangerous to our biology that's you know
and that you're making permanent changes
at a very young age i am so glad that
you guys are approaching this because it
is definitely a different conversation
it's a society thing i remember when you
know
i would do covers of magazines even in
the 80s and 90s and they would airbrush
me and i'm like
dude i'm in my teens what are you yeah
like have you made people put you back
it's great you look like a fetus you
look great
i know and i could see the slippery
slope happening but i could have never
foreseen that younger people not older
people would be leading the charge on
altering yourself so i just love
that you're having these conversations
when you're talking to people that have
differences
from your own lifestyle opinions
expertise experiences that have led you
to earn those wisdoms how do you how do
you remain a good listener because
you're doing a talk show now which is
you got to be a good talker
but how do you listen absolutely look
the table is a safe place we don't want
anyone coming on thinking that we're
we're not journalists all right we're
having a conversation excuse me three
women yeah yeah i know i want to be a
journalist
i want to be a journalist too i'm with
you go on sorry yeah but our
point is to have the conversation and to
have a conversation you have to have
people that have different opinions from
us yeah i think the key word to to learn
to listen is to go to the table
with respect for me that's the
the biggest thing having respect for
someone's opinion you know i may not
have your same opinion but i respect it
yes absolutely i really embrace people
that have different feelings experiences
and opinions than i do i've looked at
the divide in our country
and just said i want this show to be a
bright spot not a blind spot i want to
accept our differences and find
that absolutely
now i i have one last question for you
um which is that it's hispanic heritage
month and i wanted to bring something up
because
i read this article in forbes magazine
and it said
a lot of people are responding from uh
the latin community that this is not a
month to have businesses and marketing
firms check boxes
what is your thoughts about that
well i read the article as well
and i just have to say this absolutely
this should be something especially
advertisers to realize the economic
power of the latin market like latinos
may even that they can't afford it will
buy their children the top-of-the-line
shoes or you know uh nikes or whatever
comes out they all fix up their house
and they'll spend money on the things
that are of value so advertisers that
are out are ignoring this market so
absolutely and i've fought this a long
time i'm on a lot of boards in different
companies and this is one of the pet
peeves that they don't put enough
emphasis or focus on the latin market
year round now
i'll take the month because we are not
we are under representatives
[Music]
[Applause]
i agree and it's why i wanted to talk to
you because i i felt very sensitive um
where i want to bring
these breast cancer awareness month and
gay pride month and the way that we
through the holidays
tend to tap into
our
altruism and our giving and our
thoughtfulness and how can we re weave a
365 tapestry where we honor and
celebrate the best in each other accept
each other's differences and make this a
year-round thing uh without
ever ignoring what has been built and
needs to be acknowledged in these
specialized you know months so i was
very excited to talk to you guys i'm
excited to talk to you about everything
gloria lilly i mean
emily you guys i am so excited that we
are on a parallel track with each other
my love my admiration and the way that
just my heart blossoms and my mind
expands every time we get together or i
watch your shows or
getting to keep going alongside with you
is such an honor i love you so much red
table talk via stefans airs new episodes
every thursday at 9 00 a.m pacific and
12 p.m eastern on facebook watch
congratulations
[Music]
you